[Music]
our panel today looks at the the chill
effect we've all had at that moment when
you hear something in a piece of music
and shivers run down your spine or the
little hairs on the back of your neck
stand up and maari's piece alt has a
kind of ghostly quality which is why
she's chosen it for us today
[Music]
mari is obviously not the only person
that will be on our little panel our
discussion today let me introduce you to
the rest of the gang
beginning with psyche Louie she's
assistant professor currently at
Wesleyan University but about to start
taking over in the music and creativity
department at Northeastern University
please welcome psyche Louie and the
professor of psychology and neuroscience
at nyu david poeppel assistant professor
of psychology at SUNY Purchase Meghan
Curtis from the University of
Connecticut professor of physics and
psychology Edie large
so psyche you are also a violinist so
you would have known all the technical
stuff that was going into Marius piece
but was it ghostly sounding and if so
why what makes what would make a piece
have that kind of character to it I
thought it was ghostly sounding and I
think to me it comes down to the
fulfillment and violation of
expectations right so I think the piece
had a lot of dissonance I held bow noise
and I think our brains by this age right
where we're primed to to think about
sounds as being consonants especially in
music and so when you add a little bit
more you know no ways to the bow and or
you play closer to the bridge right I
mean that gives you that shivery feeling
that is dissonance and I think that
that's what makes a piece feel kind of
unexpected and eerie
[Music]
and I think it's that interplay between
the unexpected and like and then it's
kind of more consonants and resolutions
of sounds that makes us get the chills
and you do a lot of studying of this you
know vibration oscillation waveform that
sort of thing it can actually have the
opposite effect of putting people off of
kind of distancing them from what
they're hearing right sure sure you know
one of the things I mean obviously
expectation is very important but one of
the things that happens when you listen
to those kind of sounds is or any sound
is that the brainstem you know the early
parts of the auditory system literally
are are synchronizing with the sound on
a cycle by cycle basis and that has
really you know it can make even a
single sound not even two sounds in a
row but you know those kind of harmonics
that Mario was doing very emotional and
and you know really give you the chills
just that one note even but it will be a
very individual response you know what
works for one person will not work for
another
which Megan I know you you've you really
kind of have worked a lot with targeting
how individuals respond to things like
music right to a certain extent so there
there is a lot of individual variability
with how people respond to certain songs
so a song that might create an intensely
emotional experience for me might not
create any sort of experience for you
and is there a way of I mean has
neuroscience gotten to the point where
it can kind of codify what the
parameters are that make it likely for
one kind of music to affect a person
that way as opposed to another well I
think that there's there are some
predictors that can tell you who is most
likely to respond emotionally to a
certain type of piece so for instance if
you have a personal history with with
the piece if it's well known to you if
you're a musician if you've played the
piece before that's going to create a
deeper emotion
response and the context in which it
occurs is going to influence how you
respond to the music so there you know
there are some things that that do seem
to have predictive value however there
there's still tremendous variability
across different individuals right
there's a lot there that we're gonna
unpack during the course of this
conversation things like context and
expectation David it seems like maybe 25
30 years ago music and neuroscience
seemed like distinct fields and then
gradually in the wake of Oliver Sacks's
work neuroscience began to kind of look
at music and then really focus on music
and now it's like obsessed with music
what what has your experience been of
you know this kind of progression of
interest on the part of neuroscientists
we have to of course say and
neuroscience is obsessed of everything
because neuroscience can explain
everything neuroscience and so but it's
true that's the one big change has been
the availability of techniques to
measure the human brain that weren't
available 25 years ago in the last 25
years we've kind of optimized and
developed brain recording techniques
from awake behaving humans listening to
music listening to speech that allow us
to monitor what's going on and begin to
come up with kind of more satisfying
mechanistic answers and some of us work
on this and of course it's often much
more compelling and fun to study
something like music then the usual
stuff we do in the lab which is you come
to my lab you sit in a machine and you
hear beep beep beep and then 90 minutes
later you're still hearing beep that is
necessary that's how we sort of build up
the parts list of how a mind and brain
are organized but in the end we're
interested in compelling experiences
like music you know why do we find
mari's peace mesmerizing not because
it's beep beep beep because it's
something other in our head that's
going on and that's what we're trying to
figure out so if you're able to take an
fMRI for example a functional MRI of of
a brain as it's in the act of listening
to music I mean one of one of the
interesting things is music seems to
affect the brain globally it's there is
no like one part of the brain as there
is for speech music seems to be all all
over the place so let me disagree with
you already okay so there is the same is
true for speech speech is just as
complicated as music let's go right into
the meat of this right so so and you
asked Mari why does it seem ghost or a
psyche why is it ghostly well they there
is a huge individual differences which
we're going to talk about in psyches as
actually very influential recent paper
about what about the wiring diagram that
is but when I listen to it my individual
my response that was it reminded me of
animals you probably had nothing like
that in mind your dog or some bird but I
thought this was a scene of many
different animal sounds coming together
in weird ways and that was my
interpretation of it so in the privacy
of my own mind I'm entitled to interpret
music any way I like
this is not the case for speech in the
case of speech meaning is conveyed by
putting things together you can you pull
out particular words and you put the
words together to construct meaning and
that is much more directed in some sense
than it is in the musical case so we
have our own private interpretation much
more so and that's partly the you know
tremendous individual variability so if
I say to you and
man bites dog we all six of us will have
the same interpretation of what that
means as will the rest of you and if you
don't come see me later and but if you
hear even you know a few bars of music
you will not and therein lies our really
big difference and that big difference
is carried by pretty complicated
networks that are true for the speech
case and the music case so it's a
elaborated story well I think yes and no
right I mean I think that it's a bit of
a strong statement to think that if you
have one piece of music
that we don't all hear it the same way I
mean I think we can all take different
emotional interpretations from it but I
think part of the goal of composition in
a way is to align the composer's
intention with the audience's intentions
right otherwise if there's no alignment
and this is from Fred Lehrer I was just
down the street if you if there's no
alignment then you could say that a
piece is kind of failing right and so we
have to find the common gripe use ich
ins have to find the common ground
between what we're making and what the
audience is hearing and I think that
that comes down to like I was having
similarly wired brains to a certain
extent but of course there's lots of
differences so I mean I think that it's
not so simple that you just can take
whatever you want I would have music I
think that there are some commonalities
and coming from the other side that's
because I'm on your other side and it's
it's it's not as though language is that
simple either I mean I mean man bites
dog is one thing but a more complicated
more complicated sentence more
complicated discourse people interpret
in many different ways also so and
that's one of the interesting things
about language and music is it's got
this multi-faceted kind of meaning that
we can that we can see well coming from
the other the other side the other side
as an interpreter I mean I do classical
whatever right any here trained in the
violin you know that you have to
practice the same thing over and over
and over and over again until you're
technically right so how do you keep
yourself fresh and how do you present
yourself emotionally coherent to the
audience so that you're not just tracing
your notes right so what I do personally
this is like behind the no but we just
write my own process I use the
Stanislavski like a you know actors a
method acting I read a lot of
Stanislavski when I was young and I
built my own emotional self context
right so I learned early on that if I
practice
practice it's I just am bored on stage I
done this before and if I'm bored you
work so you know not for me not to
reward I have to build the sub context
of emotions so that I can follow that
thing but then I have to choose a
subtext
maybe day or two before maybe the
conversation I had a book I read I knew
so I saw some story that I kind of lay
out emotionally and then you know I that
way I can present that but then you are
not seeing that you don't know the book
I read but emotional logic is there so
you can follow the that's how I do it I
want to come back to this idea that if
you as a performer aren't or as a
composer aren't feeling it that the
audience won't feel it because there was
a study done some years ago about job
satisfaction and orchestral musicians
ranked slightly below sanitation workers
in the fact that we can go to an
orchestral concert and have a really
amazing experience which is being played
to us apparently by a hundred and four
people who are bored out of their tiny
minds is is a little weird and I mean
we've each picked a piece of music to
share with you today that that for each
of us gives us that that shiver that
chill effect and psyche you picked an
orchestral piece does it matter to you
if you know that that Orchestra has been
sawing through this piece you know all
week long and is sick of the sound of it
and or just doing what the you know
because it's a job I mean does that
I mean I actually almost chose to become
Kestrel musician and then didn't and I
think it is because you know if this
feeling that if you're doing the same
thing over and over again each day it
might get boring instead of being the
thing that you love but I mean but I
don't think that's completely true mean
I think that my friends who choose to go
into music professionally they choose it
not because they're not good at anything
else it's just because they can't like
imagine dedicating their life to
something else which I think says
something about why music is so
important because like it's it's it's
doing something to you emotionally and
it's it's triggering your reward system
it's hopefully it's good for your brain
there's lots of them lots of work on
that as well
but I think at the end of the day like
even when the board orchestral musician
is performing on stage in a concert I
think they do enter a different world
that is professional and this together
and it's kind of in it for the greater
good I mean I think that the other stuff
is you know maybe like administration I
mean all these other things that well I
think there's also a question of agency
you know musicians like to make the
music that they want to play and when
you're an orchestral musician you play
the music you're told to play in the way
that the conductor is you know at his or
her tempo and you know you're waiting
for your cue etc so there is a question
of agency I mean with all due respect to
Orchestra I know many of them and they
they're deeply committed but there is
that they're not getting that little pop
that that you're getting when you hear
this piece explain what this piece does
for you Second Piano Concerto second
movement and I chose the beginning of it
it's really
[Music]
so it's kind of a hushed tremulous
opening there yeah I think it's setting
up a lot of action that's about to
happen
and I think that feeling of anticipation
there's also a lot of chord changes and
we know from John Szabo does work in
1989 91 that chord changes are more
likely to elicit that feeling of of like
of your heart skipping a beat
whereas melodic changes and certainly I
mean there's music theoretical
predictors for like how you make these
melodic changes but those are more
likely to make people cry right so so
you have different kinds of strong
emotional responses that are triggered
by different kind of compositional
devices and which is like why I think
that I mean and I think that composers
kind of implicitly know about these
types of devices and that's why they're
able to deploy these tools of music
theory to make a rewarding experience
for audience when you get to you know
things like rhythm you're you're getting
back aren't you to the lizard brain the
you know the the brain stem and the you
know the fact that we learn early on to
entrain to a beat I mean isn't so I mean
it's sort of comes back to what I was
saying before about music affecting
different parts of the brain on a
physical level right you know that part
edie of the brain is being right being
raised as well as that it's not just the
brain stem for rhythm it's it's auditory
cortex it's motor cortex it's the basal
ganglia and you know these parts of the
brain have intrinsic rhythms and and you
know there's a lot we don't know about
the brain but one of the things we do
know is that it communicates within
itself via rhythms and and different
kinds of of oscillations that are going
on and one of the most I think amazing
discoveries in the past 20 years is that
when we listen to musical rhythm our
brains synchronize those intrinsic
rhythms to the rhythms of music that's
the that's the process known as entrain
treatment
yeah does your musical example give us
you know a sense of that yet so I picked
one that that yeah would exactly show
that off and it happens to be so so one
of the things that happens when we
listen to rhythmic music it happens to
everybody is you'll find yourself
tapping your foot or bopping your head
this and and that feature of music that
makes you want to move has been termed
groove by one of our colleagues Peter
janata and he did a large study of all
different kinds of older music and newer
music and had undergraduates rate the
groove and this piece that I chose was
the one that they consistently chose as
number one and I do this experiment in
my class every year my undergraduates
consistently choose this number one even
though it's from the 70s so it's
superstition by Stevie Wonder when the
clavinet comes in yeah you know and adds
its layer to the groove that's already
been established then it's just like I
mean then the brain is suddenly like
what just happened yeah right what would
that look like
David on it you know if if you had
hooked one of EDS undergrads up to an
fMRI while that was happening any idea
we could take any of you and hook you up
not so much in an fMRI fMRI is a
wonderful camera it's a camera that
takes pictures with very high spatial
resolution but it's to capture this kind
of thing you need a machine that
actually has high temporal resolution so
you can follow the rhythm so fMRI is not
so great that you want something like
EEG which many of us use or it's big
cousin Magneto and sefa log Rafi you
know a giant recorder of brain activity
and what you see and what we can measure
is how different parts of the brain and
train right so it's the brain is
hijacked by rhythm
but say you can't stop yourself and you
see the brain activity the waves of the
brain surfing on the waves of the sound
and it's sort of inescapable right so
the sound can be it can be kind of
conceptualized as a series of waves that
we can analyze in all kinds of ways and
the brain activity literally surfs on
top of that whether it wants to or not
so you're seeing movement motions as
well you see I mean that's how we
visually see the so the brain so Ed
mentioned you know that the rhythmic
brain activity in different areas or we
call them neural oscillations and you
can imagine that is the brain breathing
at different rates right so at this
level of single cells or local networks
or larger networks the brain is
breathing at faster rates and slower
rates it has to do with biological
factoids that we don't have to unpack
here for fear of losing your audience
but these are sort of optimally suited
to grab on to the rotisserie of the
piece so when you're listening to
superstition different parts from the
periphery to the central part of the
brain literally are just locking on
we're in training to this and so you you
can't stop yourself how much of this
Megan do you think is cultural would
would an Australian Aborigine in the you
know in the outback be as quick to
entrain to the groove of a Stevie Wonder
as anybody who grew up with you know
Western pop music well perhaps you know
there is some evidence that the emotions
that are perceived in music are
perceived to a certain extent at a
universal level so if you are an
individual from a particular culture
you're going to be better at identifying
emotion in music from your culture than
you would for other cultures that have
music that you're less familiar with
however you'd still identify the emotion
above chance and what that tells us is
that there are some Universal features
that are used to detect emotion in music
so when we think about emotional
responses to music it's actually helpful
to distinguish between the affective
response that you have and what is being
communicated by the music and within a
given culture there are these these
codes that exist that tell the listener
this is a sad song or this is a happy
song or this song is a you know I'm
going to induce fear and those coats are
fairly well established and agreed upon
by listeners within a culture so one of
the interesting things that you'll see
is that listeners will very quickly
identify an emotion that's communicated
by the music they can do so after
hearing only a quarter of a second of a
song and the the level of agreement
between listeners is actually really
high particularly within cultures now
how that translates to your emotional
experience you know the emotions that
you feel in response to the song that's
a different question so you have what's
being communicated by the music and then
you have the factors that lead to you
actually experiencing an emotion and the
field really makes a distinction between
the two you sound like you probably
familiar with the work of Thomas Fritz
among the mafia people where he I mean
the Mafia live in the Highlands I guess
of Cameroon and had minimal contact with
the West and Western music and he went
there with a series of pieces of music
and a happy face a sad face and a scared
face and consistently the maava were
able to hearing western music for the
first time or you know keyboard music
for the first time that he had brought
to them we're consistently able to
identify correctly the emotion and then
even more unusually he brought some
mafia music back to Germany and the
people there were able to identify
correctly you know the emotions that
that that music was was carrying I
wonder for you Mari having did you grow
up with traditional Japanese music as
well as Western oh yeah I grew up in
Japan I was telling you producer that
there's a song children's song it's very
innocent folks
[Music]
it's like your happy son yeah it's a
song about little bubbles here blowing
bubbles and bubbles fly to the ceiling
the roof
oh it hit the ceiling and he disappears
oh we don't you know blow let the let
the bubbles fly and it's just just as
innocent song and then it turned out the
composer's daughter died so the lyrics
is about the daughter who died so he
said don't you know kill mine and my
daughter so after I knew that I cannot
listen to you in the same way yeah so
it's like very I grew up singing that
song but now I can't you know it I
relate in a different way okay so this
this gets to an interesting question
which is let's say just for sake of
argument that this I know this isn't
true but let's just say that everybody
who grew up on Western pop music hearing
the opening of superstition is going to
get that little pop of dopamine or
whatever you know that little hit that
little shiver down the spine when that
keyboard comes in would that happen when
that listener is 2 or 3 or does that
listener have to have some experience to
know sometime een at what point does
your own cultural and individual
experience completely alter or color
your response to music so you know it's
interesting you know and and a lot of
people make this mistake they think well
you know I sit down I listen to music I
start tapping my foot immediately
therefore it's you know it's innate its
inborn somehow but in fact there's a
long trajectory to the development of
rhythm perception and and rhythmic
interaction with music so turns out
infants if you test infants the day
after they're born you play them
different kinds of sounds you play them
speech you play the music they'll move
more to music but they won't synchronize
they they can't synchronize
it turns out that if you play them
rhythms from the Western culture and
Balkan cultures like Bulgaria they can
tell the difference between those
rhythms when they're six months old but
by the time they're twelve months old
they undergo perceptual narrowing and
now they can't make those distinctions
similarly to speech or to phases and
it's it kids that are two and a half
three and a half of four and a half
years old still can't synchronize very
well but they think ranae's better if
there's a person in the room to
synchronize with and it's there six or
seven years old before most kids can
really you know dance in synchrony with
music you know I mean there are
exceptions right right Justin Bieber
being one right I mean you've seen the
movies but you know they're sort of
rhythmic you know rhythmic geniuses out
there but you know most kids there are
six or seven before they can really
think Rijn eyes with music but you know
even to come back to what David what you
were saying about Mary's piece alt that
you know you heard something in it that
she probably hadn't intended but three
or four year old David Pepper might not
have known what to make of that you know
I mean there's you you're bringing a
lifetime of auditory experience you
bring and one of the the delicious parts
of human experiences that we have a hard
disk of life in our head that colors
everything so what we bring to every
experience at whether it's music the
visual arts dance theater that what the
art historian bounced gumbush called the
beholders share I think a beautiful
phrase and so for me the beholders share
to your piece was finding something
different in them you know so I don't
want to skew this discussion too much
towards meaning but I will anyway the
because a second example that just came
up is the one you gave with the Japanese
children's song which you know you hear
for the first time you think oh that has
a cheerful thing the moment you tell the
story it colors it in a completely
different way right so now I too cannot
hear this
it's kind of oh this is joyful you know
Radha but the balloons are flying up or
the bottle blowing bubbles knowledge is
a dangerous thing
and knowledge your preconceived what the
priors you bring with you to a
perceptual experience color your
interpretation of that and so it can be
high and that that of course invariably
leads to individual differences because
we all have slightly different things on
our heart that's good and your hard disk
includes a little area devoted to the
music of Tom Waits
which surprisingly big area so yes I am
to the to the dismay of my my my wife
and sons who were all musicians
incidentally I am a deep fan of Tom
Waits and I selected a song for a
particular reason I think it makes a few
interesting points called Kentucky
Avenue which is about childhood
[Music]
scratch your initials in my arm was for
your how to sneak up on a roof
[Music]
oh so this one works for me every time
okay so I get and why did I well I
selected this simply because I'd like it
but it makes a couple of points that I
think are germane to our discussion one
is the so this is about childhood right
this is a song about but all the weird
stuff that happens when you're a kid and
the compelling effect it has on your
head so the stuff you know you first
time you heard certain things or you
fell in love where you kissed for the
first time or you had some awful
experience with a parent anything the
stuff in your childhood has a
particularly compelling grip on things
that's one point so our experiences
early on really a color stuff later very
profoundly the second point I think is
which is interesting and I think we you
know it's easy to overlook although we
all have this experience is that
material that's putative ly sad which
this song is can give you a positive
aesthetic experience right so sad things
are supposed to be sad and in real life
sad things are sad we don't seek bad
experiences we seek positive experiences
but in the arts one of the fascinating
things is that a negatively colored
emotionally things can be experienced as
wonderful and aesthetically engaging and
moving and that's one of the most
exciting things about the arts and in
music really brings it out in this
magnificent way yeah Megan you've done a
lot of work with this sort of the
behavioral kind of responses I mean what
is it about the sad song that we keep
coming back to it well it might be that
it's one of the safe ways that we can
experience this emotion without having
any sort of personal consequences I mean
you know in when you have a sadness
that's evoke through you know
traditional ecological means it's
because you've experienced a personal
loss no one wants that
but music and art in general gives us
the chance to explore these emotions
that we tend to avoid because they have
no consequences in this context so we
can go to the theater and enjoy being
really frightened
because we know that we're not in danger
and music may be doing this at the same
type of thing where it gives us the
chance to explore negative emotions in a
way that have
no consequences for us yeah and I think
that it's really about experiencing a
certain beautiful thing together right
the fact that we're in it together I
mean I think that a lot of the
experience of music moves us because
it's kind of a resonant emotional
experience across a lot of people and so
we've done some work looking at brain
differences between people who get
chills when often get chills when they
listen to music compared to people who
don't when you know controlling for all
these different variables and it seems
like the auditory areas are actually
more connected to areas of the brain
that are important for social and
emotional processing among people who
always get chills so it's as if great
when you're listening to something
that's beautiful
it's a songwriters way of going straight
to your social and emotional processing
regions of the brain through an auditory
channel so Megan the music that you
chose for us is a sad song it is but
it's a very different kind of sad song
from Tom Waits
you know lonely guy at the bar at
closing time sort of this is I'm sad and
I'm storming the gates of heaven to let
the universe know it what was what is it
about this excerpt from the Mozart
Requiem that that does it for you so one
of the things that happens in the clip
we're going to hear is that Mozart
created this beautiful melodic line that
doesn't resolve in a way that you expect
it to so the end of the melodic line
ends on a the seventh scale degree and
we generally expect that to resolve to a
very stable scale degree in music that
we call the tonic and that doesn't
happen and I think that leaves the
listener wanting more and it gives you
this this sense of you know lack of
fulfillment yet there's there's such
beauty in that and there's mystery and
for me it definitely causes all sorts of
emotions well this is so this is some of
the lacrimosa
from the Mozart Requiem
[Music]
suddenly want to buy a car been using a
car commercial reason which is pretty
telling actually you know what kind of I
don't remember the brand but it's a
reason but but this piece has been used
in films many I mean you know this this
has that that especially what we heard
at the end where the the voice has come
back in that's that's become a kind of
iconic musical moment you know in film
and TV shows and music music consultants
love this piece because it has a lot of
emotional content not necessarily the
one that the text would would lead you
to expect as lacrimosa is tears in latin
but this people hear something grand in
this and something elegant and you know
so this night so you said there's lots
of emotion in this for you what are you
here well one of the interesting things
about this melodic line is that for me
it reminds me of the sound of someone
crying hmm so you know the fact that it
is locking mosa tears may have some
direct relevance to how he decided to
create that line maybe he was trying to
emulate the types of sounds that people
create when they're crying so for me
this this taps into this very basic type
of sadness response and yet it's not my
sadness so for me that that becomes
translated into an aesthetic response
rather than me you know becoming
personally sad instead I appreciate the
beauty of it so if you're feeling a kind
of response on a purely aesthetic level
are you less likely to get that shiver
effect than if you're actually
responding to it is if you know that's
your emotion that's being prodded
well the shiver is thought to be an
aesthetic reason
yeah oftentimes the the songs that are
most able to create the Shiva response
our sad songs yet people say that the
the response is highly positive people
generally don't think that they're
feeling sadness when they experience
this extreme emotional response so the
you know what is being communicated by
the piece may be very different than
what is being experienced by the
listener the listener response may be
highly pleasurable even though the piece
is really sad and actually that kind of
brings us to the piece that I chose
which is something I've only recently
discovered and which I'm not sure I know
how to set up other than to say it's a
man and a woman in a room in their
living room if they're a Bruce green and
cor Loy mcwhirter I think they're
married they're in North Carolina and
they sing old folk songs like generally
lesser-known pretty dark you know the
what what the critic grill mark is
called weird old America you know the
and it's it's it's one microphone
there's no reverb it's just two voices
singing I'll say together but you can
decide for yourself the song is called
come near my love
[Music]
things that you should know have a night
shining moon I'm bound to be leaving I'm
bound to turn my head and go so I don't
know what the hell is happening there I
mean harmony but what kind I'm a fourth
parallel fourth but they but it's not
it's not tempered it's not the parallel
fourth sometimes if they sound like
they're droning first of all you know
rather than sitting down to the fourth
right and yeah so and it but it again
it's not a it's not a tempered it's a
pure yeah it's so it's wrong it's not
it's not the fourth that you'll get at a
piano or a guitar although you could do
it
[Laughter]
you know I I'm often listening to music
while I'm doing other things and I just
stuck this CD and because a friend
recommended it and I was just like
rooted to the spot as what is that
because it was unexpected and you know
just like different from anything that I
had heard from you know Mountain
Appalachian the high lonesome sound it's
definitely not that it's definitely not
Nashville style harmony is it was just
really kind of unexpected well you know
it's funny you started out the
conversation by saying well you know
thirty years ago there was no music
neuroscience and so forth but really
music has been studied in science since
there was science at least in the West
and Mari brought up Pythagoras you know
Pythagoras was some that's considered by
some of the first scientists in the West
and his question was exactly that why
did it why to two notes why do those two
notes sound so good together you know
and we're still asking the question
right and why we should not let these
two notes play together because they
make people do impure things
so that hole and you know that that
lasted I mean do you know Italy early in
the 18th century Johann Matheson in
Germany the effect in Lera a doctrine of
the different effects that scales would
you know this scale will make people
slit their wrists this people will make
people run out and you know make bad
decisions with the next person of the
opposite sex that they meet and this was
really you know this was seen as science
and you know well you know I mean I
think you know a lot of thinking like
that went way off the tracks right but
there's also a lot of good evidence that
there are physiological responses that
that that we have the brain going back
to the brain stem responses in the brain
stem in the early auditory system that
that correspond to our feelings of you
know what this harmony makes us feel I
mean you can almost in that song you
played you can almost just hear one
harmony you doesn't even need to
progress and you can already feel an
emotional and emotionality out of that
so I don't think although you know it
has for the past couple hundred years
been you know very fashionable to
discount that that way of thinking I
think people are beginning to come back
and say no way maybe there really is
something about the way we respond to
individual intervals that's really
important give me some news you can use
why is this important to study what does
it tell us what what if any use is is
this scientifically behaviorally you
mean music in general no this this our
exploration of these kind of emotional
in the physical effect look I mean I
think we shouldn't have to justify this
so let me disagree with the question the
premise of the question so obviously
there's an it is a world science
festival
so yes but so that's why you know we do
science because we're we can't help
ourselves trying to understand stuff and
so there's a deep value to basic
research there has to be no nugget so it
turns out that there is because there's
fascinating therapeutic complications I
understand but from my point of view we
do basic science to simply understand
the parts list we're here we're trying
to understand the parts list of the mind
the brain and music and so there are two
things that can happen we can use music
to understand something about music and
something about the mind and brain and
we can use neurobiological methods to
understand something about music these
are perfectly valuable and reasonable
things and there has to be no end game
if there's a pill or a lotion or a car I
can buy it matters not okay so we do
basic science because we're wired to
have we have a science forming faculty
we just try to understand stuff and
that's very important and we should not
forget that part of science is just that
it's not trying to come up with a with
an application it's to satisfy curiosity
and to let our minds wander in weird
directions and say damn that was
interesting and turns out music is an
extremely well-structured domain to
learn something about how the mind and
brain are organized and that's deeply
exciting and satisfying yeah yeah I
can't agree with that more I mean I but
I also think that the reason why I do
science is so that I can understand more
things and so that I can be more
open-minded towards new ideas right I
mean before I started doing this it was
like oh of course you listened to Mozart
because he was genius because he sounded
good and he was good because of all
these you know all these ways but then
you hear about other people who are here
who are deriving different experiences
from the same thing you know like the
Laura yeah neolution I mean and then
that you're thinking about that just
makes you appreciate like diversity more
it makes you more open-minded I think
Megan do you have more of an application
based approach well I think that
addressing this question in general
raises new questions about the nature of
music and the significance to the human
species so if you look at the brain
areas that
that have the strongest response when
someone is experiencing chills you see
that they are the same brain areas that
are involved in rewarding behavior that
has biological significance so acquiring
food having sex and these brain areas
are also responsive to drugs so when we
see that music is activating these
reward centers we have to ask well does
it have any sort of biological value for
humans or is it hijacking these systems
in the same way that drugs do and that's
an open question but I think this type
of research raises those questions and
those questions are important to
understanding what is music and and why
is it important to humans now that you
had well I want to start out by agreeing
with David because I'm a hundred percent
I think he he's right on with that I
think but I want to add two things to it
what one he touched on which is with
music music is so well structured that
it allows us to go and see the brain
when we you know use EEG or M eg we can
see with the rhythms of music we can see
so clearly that brain entrainment you
know people like David have spent a lot
of time of studying speech and it's in
some ways the structure is not quite as
clear but in music we were able to first
go in and say oh my gosh the brain is
really in training to music and then
pretty soon people like David were
saying hey guess what it's happening for
speech too so so so it gives us a kind
of a of a way to focus the brain on this
rhythmic thing and then I will go and
talk about some applications so it turns
out that there are a lot of kind of
disorders of the brain in which you find
people also have a problem with rhythm
okay so autistic kids have a problem
with rhythm people with specific
language impairment people with dyslexia
and there are other ways in which so
we're not exactly quite sure what that
means yet but there are other very clear
ways in which people are using music
therapy to clinical benefit so to help
people rehabilitate speech after a
stroke for example with melodic
intonation there
your rhythmic stimulation can help
people rehabilitate their gait if they
have Parkinson's disease so there there
really are we are beginning to
understand that there may actually be
some clinical applications to music and
a lot of them have to do with rhythm
well it's it's funny that we're coming
to this realization at a time where
there are lots of musicians who are kind
of pushing at the borders of what we
consider to be music as opposed to noise
and you know bringing I mean that that
we could go down a whole rabbit hole but
instead I think what we're going to do
is open the floor to questions from you
folks yeah in talking about the
fundamental processes involved in
engaging with music and talking about
with Missa tee that suggests if it's so
fundamental that it would be happening
in other species as well so what kinds
of properties here generalize hint that
we can tell generalize the experiences
that say dogs or apes or others have of
music oh that's a really great question
is that Finn by the way - so Lance a
question in the audience I did not plant
a question but I'm glad she acid um
they're they're a bunch of really
exciting studies going on right now I
don't know probably many of you in the
audience have seen snowball the dancing
cockatoo and people raise their hand
just so I get an idea of yeah so you can
go on YouTube dances to the Backstreet
Boys it's very sort of it looks like
he's having a really great time so one
of my colleagues Ani Patel or - and
johnny patel and johnny verson went and
actually studied snowball and found that
snowball is in fact doing a pretty good
job of synchronizing it's intermittent
synchronization so snowball goes in and
out but statistically you know they
measure it statistically is pretty well
synchronized but so then another
colleague of mine Peter Cook decided to
teach a sea lion to synchronize and this
is Ronin who's also you can see on the
web Ronin
and ronan synchronizes as well as a
person I mean just never miss literally
never misses a beat so there are some
animals we have done some preliminary
work with a bonobo just playing the
drums and trying to get the the bonobo
to synchronize and the bonobo dub will
synchronize with drum sounds the thing
about some of these other animals
they'll actually synchronize to music
which we haven't gotten there at the
bonobos yet so there are some people who
say well you know it's really a human
thing or you really need to be a vocal
learning species but then there are
other people things like groan and
suggest well maybe it is more widespread
and at least the capability to
synchronize maybe not the motivation per
se but yeah alright let's uh let's take
one more question yes gentleman in the
blue shirt here hi my mom has dementia
she's in her 90s and in a conversation
she may not remember what you've said 30
seconds before but she can recall the
old hymns word for word or if you put on
Glenn Miller or Tommy Dorsey or
something she's back out on the dance
floor with my dad what's going on there
and how can it help people with
Alzheimer's and dementia I mean we know
that the we have this network in our
brain called the default Network that's
constantly on and that and especially an
area in the frontal lobe medial
prefrontal cortex tends to have less
activity over time as you age and in
people with Alzheimer's it's really much
less activity and so what I think the
music is doing is kind of acting this a
rejuvenator of that system so that
you're increasing activity in those
regions that that might then last a
little while yeah I mean I think you
know the brain is a funny thing and you
know people talk about the brain as if
it's a computer right and we want to
know how you know this little cog works
with that little wheel and so forth but
if you know what we learn when we study
the brain is that it just doesn't work
that way it works in all kinds of
counterintuitive ways another thing that
you might know is that if you have a
stroke and you lose your ability to
speak there's a very good
possibility that you will preserve your
ability to sing and that's now being
exploited in you know melodic intonation
therapy and so forth and on that note
let me thank all of you for being here
and our wonderful
[Applause]
[Music]